y ahora vamos a seguir trabajando con
las leyes de los exponentes y vamos a
seguir obteniendo dos de ellas que son
para mí de mis favoritas estás leídos de
exponentes primero vamos a verlas para
un caso particular y después podemos
pensar en ellas en un caso general y
para esto vamos a utilizar todas las
propiedades que ya no sabemos así que
empezamos a trabajar con dos números
imagínate que en un primer número se
llama am y mi otro número le voy a poner
el nombre de be ok tengo aa por ven ya
estos dos los quiero elevar los quiero
elevar a la cuarta potencia a estos dos
los quiero elevar a la cuarta potencia
como puedo obtener el resultado de esto
que tengo aquí
bueno pues utilicemos las definiciones
que ya no sabemos esto es exactamente lo
mismo y ahora déjenme atrapar estos dos
para poderlos utilizar
de una manera más rápida
esto me va a quedar control cm
ok me va a quedar a este x sí mismo
cuatro veces ok por este ok ya esto
lo vamos a multiplicar una vez más ok ya
esto lo voy a multiplicar otra vez más
entonces me quedan aporte por aporte por
aborden por haber ven y bueno esto es
exactamente lo mismo y aquí podemos
utilizar que podemos conmutar las letras
y entonces me quedaría a a
por a por a por a y después a esto lo
voy a multiplicar por b
por ver
ven
por ver de tal manera que tengo cuatro
veces multiplicándose y puedo concluir
que esta parte de aquí es exactamente lo
mismo que tener a un elevado a la cuarta
potencia a por am por abraham es lo
mismo que ha elevado a la cuarta
potencia y esto a su vez está
multiplicando
avn avn multiplicándose por sí misma
cuatro veces lo cual me da b elevada
también a la cuarta potencia b elevada a
la cuarta potencia y justo a lo que
estoy llegando es que a paul b esto que
tengo aquí elevado a la cuarta potencia
elevado a la cuarta potencia es
exactamente lo mismo que ha elevado a la
cuarta potencia por b elevado a la
cuarta potencia y bueno si tú te das
cuenta que tome el 4 como un número al
azar pero también ya no podemos pensar
de una manera un poco más general
nosotros podemos decir
a por de amor de elevado a cualquier
potencia y se me ocurre no sé tomarme va
a volver elevado a la potencia cm esto
es exactamente lo mismo que ha elevado a
la cm que ha elevado a la potencia ce ya
su vez esto multiplicado por b elevado
también a la potencia c también a la
potencia cm y bueno la demostración te
puedes dar cuenta que es muy parecido a
esto que tenemos aquí y en este vídeo no
solamente quiero ver esta propiedad que
se me hace muy importante sino que
también quiero ver otra propiedad más de
las leyes de los exponentes pero para
esto un agente que yo me tomo a un
número a yo me voy a tomar a a ok ya
está a la voy a elevar la voy a elevar a
la potencia se me ocurre al cubo y
después voy a llevar esto y déjame
copiarlo una vez voy a llevar esto de
aquí
copiar de una vez voy a elevar esto de
aquí todo a la potencia 2 a la potencia
2 que voy a obtener de esta operación
que tengo aquí bueno pues vamos a
utilizar otra vez las leyes de los
exponentes para ver que me queda de esto
al cubo al cuadrado pues es lo mismo que
tomarme al cubo déjame ponerlo justo
aquí ya esto a multiplicarlo por al cubo
ya esto x al cubo es justo la definición
de un cuadrado esto es a kubica por a
kubica y esto es exactamente lo mismo
nosotros sabemos que cuando tenemos una
base elevada a una potencia por una base
elevada a otra potencia en la misma la
potencia se conservan ok me quedaría ha
elevado a la suma de las dos potencias
es decir me va a quedar 33
+ 3 que por cierto y esto es exactamente
lo mismo y lo voy a escribir así como a
elevado a la sexta potencia ha elevado a
la sexta potencia ahora date cuenta que
tres más tres a esto de aquí lo podemos
ver de la siguiente manera 3 más 3
es lo mismo que tomarme dos veces tres o
dos por amd por tres dicho de otra
manera que lo que hicimos aquí fue
empezar con ha elevado al cubo y a esto
lo llevamos a su vez al cuadrado y nos
dimos cuenta que es multiplicar las
potencias dos por tres es seis y
llegamos a la conclusión de que es
elevada a la sexta potencia
ok tal vez sea hora de ponerlo de una
forma más general si yo tengo a un
elevado no sé a la potencia b elevado a
la potencia b y esto a su vez elevado a
la potencia c y esto a su vez elevado a
la potencia cm esto va a ser
igual y bueno yo me podría tomar este ha
elevado a la vez vamos a tomar lo ha
elevado la vez es esta parte de aquí ok
y vamos a ponerla a veces entonces me va
a quedar una vez por acá ok
otra vez por acá ok
otra vez por acá ok y nos podemos seguir
manteniendo haciendo esto mismo yo no
puedo tener aquí puntitos voy a
multiplicar cuantas veces sea necesario
ha elevado a la vez hasta llegar a ce
veces y aquí voy a tener de nuevo a
elevado a la vez para que en total de
todas las veces que estamos
multiplicando a la vez sean c veces
entonces de aquí y aquí tengo ce veces
multiplicándose aa la b c veces y bueno
déjame bajar un poco la pantalla puedo
decir ahora bajemos un poco en la
pantalla algo más unos como por aquí que
esto de aquí es exactamente lo mismo
esto es exactamente lo mismo que tomarme
a am ya la vez las potencias se van a
sumar esto es ha elevado a la vez más
más ve y si no puedo continuar sumando y
sumando y sumando tantas veces como c
veces sea necesario es decir de más de
más 90 veces dicho de otra manera aquí
tengo la suma de b consigo mismas veces
porque aquí tengo ha elevado a la vez c
veces o dicho otra manera como aquí
tengo c veces a b sumándose entonces
puedo concluir que esto es exactamente
lo mismo que ha elevado a la potencia
bem elevado a la potencia b y a su vez
multiplicado esta vez multiplicada por
ser entonces ha elevado a la b elevado a
su vez el hacer es exactamente lo mismo
que ha elevado al ave por ser muy bien
aquí está otra de las de esos exponentes
que me parece muy importante porque esto
sí lo podemos ver algún ejemplo
imagínate que nosotros tenemos am se me
ocurre 35 35 ^ ^
y esto y esto a su vez lo elevamos a la
potencia número 7 y bueno quiero que te
des cuenta que 35 elevado al cubo
elevado a las siete es un número un muy
grande pero realmente lo que quiero es
que apliquemos el concepto que acabamos
de ver esto es exactamente lo mismo que
35 que 35 y ahora voy a simplificar un
poco las potencias
estas dos potencias las voy a juntar
multiplicando las tres por 7 es 21 y
entonces es mucho mejor ver 35 elevado a
la potencia 21 que 35 elevado al cubo
elevado a la potencia número 7 y ya está
acabamos de ver una forma mucho más
simplificada de obtener una respuesta
utilizando lo que acabamos de ver con
las leyes de los exponentes